marie audrey allard revenait de montréal
en soirée dimanche lorsqu'il a aperçu
une jeune automobiliste en panne et l'a
décidé de lui venir en aide
pendant que on est en train de discuter
moyen de voitures qui est arrivé s'est
stationné à l'arrière de nous et loyak
quatre personnes qui sont sorties deux
hommes deux femmes qui étaient habillés
normalement elle qui avait l'air gentil
mon premier réflexe a été de faire il ya
des hommes qui viennent nous aider on va
être capable de régler ça mais elles ont
rapidement compris qu'il ne s'agissait
pas de bon samaritain
il y avait une femme qui avait une
longue jupe blanche s'est installé à mes
pieds je commençais à m'embrasser les
pieds à commencer par la suite a même
fait des bénédictions à me toucher les
brom bnrm embrasser la paix veut dire à
quel point si on était là aujourd'hui
c'est parce que dieu voulait qu'on se
rencontre un homme aurait également
lancé au loin le cellulaire de l'autre
jeune femme
prétextant que la technologie n'a pas sa
place dans la société
après plus de dix minutes de malaise et
de chants religieux
coincé sur le bord de l'autoroute 50
l'animatrice a composé le 9 1 1 et a
réussi à s'enfuir
sharp a finalement de taureaux et j
étais le plus vite possible jusqu'à
gatineau et plus vite possible
j'ai voulu extrêmement vite j'avais
vraiment peur qu'ils me suivent les deux
femmes sont finalement retournées chez
elles sans graves conséquences
marie andrée a tout de même eu la
frousse de sa vie selon la sûreté du
québec c'est le premier incident du
genre à survenir en outaouais le porte
parole fait cette recommandation le soir
et la nuit
si les gens sont créatifs on a souvent
ça donc je serai appelé les policiers
machines et véhicules est à l'endroit
mais nous on va demander ce que vous
avez arrêté les gens vous disais non
j'avais pas je voulais pas donc nous il
ya aucun problème on va les vérifier
c'est notre travail devant walchhofer
pour marie andré allard la leçon et bien
apprise c'est la première et la dernière
fois qu'elle arrêtait porter assistance
à une automobiliste en panne sur le bord
de l'autoroute
ici le riz trudel radio-canada
montebello